China's economic recovery is losing
momentum that's according to official
data for may retail sales Rose by 12.7
percent sowing from 18.4 percent in the
previous month industrial production
expanded 3.5 down from A 5.6 rise in
April both missed estimates weaker
Global demand for exports is also
Weighing on the economy
the international environment is complex
and severe World economic growth is
sluggish the domestic economy is
recovering but market demand is still
insufficient and some structure problems
are more prominent
worse than
fee employment has record high of 20.8
percent
more than 11.5 million graduates are
expected to enter the job market
there are so many students graduating
this year but there aren't enough jobs
we're fighting for these jobs
it paints a gloomy picture many expected
a bigger rebound after strict
coronavirus controls ended China's
heavy-handed pandemic restrictions have
been over for months people are now free
to shop eat out and travel but consumer
confidence here remains stubbornly weak
many people are simply not comfortable
spending a large amount of their savings
that sentiment is reflected in the
housing sector property investment
contracted 7.2 percent in the first five
months compared to the same period in
2022 construction of new homes plunged
the central bank has reduced the rate on
its one-year loans for the first time in
10 months and there are calls for
Beijing to do more but analysts say the
government will avoid large-scale
measures for fear of Orvis stimulating
the economy Beijing essentially tried to
deflate the bubble on its own terms
um it has no intention of going back to
re-inflating that bubble and uh and and
the larger story of course here is that
there is a concerted effort to change
the Chinese growth model that old model
that relied on very high levels of
investment which of course meant high
levels of debt authorities are
downplaying concerns and say the economy
will pick up momentum later this year
they insist China is still on track to
hit a GDP Target of around five percent
for 2023. Katrina